they're you know the cycles of success
are are
never linear they're always news and you
need to have a lot of resilience and a
lot of great rewards
in order to succeed
[Music]
tall talkner thank you for joining me on
20 minute leaders how are you
i'm great i'm really excited to be here
thank you so much for having me
well i'm really excited that you were
here so where are you calling from right
now
i'm calling from our office in tel aviv
okay the pico offices
the pico offices that's right wonderful
wonderful okay well
well i'm glad to see that things are
still that still are still happening
there even though
you know the situation is so dire but
hopefully by the time this airs
it'll it'll die down a bit and things
will get a little bit better first i
want to talk about morning dance parties
what is that lot
all about oh my goodness so i have
an incredible morning routine that
includes writing and gratitude and
meditation and a bit of yoga
but my favorite part is blasting the
music that
you know wakes up all my neighbors super
early and just dancing that off the wall
i love it i love it i've been trying to
get into a morning routine myself but i
and
everybody's been telling me about the
meditation and gratitude part i think
that i'm going to start by adopting this
morning dance party
and then move on to those because that
seems like a like a really nice part of
it
and tal you know i'm going to let you
talk a little bit about your journey
because i'm not going to be able to do
justice but just as a small recap
currently an investor within pico
within pico you are also a forbes 30
under 30
founded several organizations wmn a part
of them
but you also did a lot of other work in
terms of female empowerment and
leadership
globally not just in tech and i'd love
to actually get started with that in
just a second and then weave the
conversation into
sort of how you invest within pico and
what are your
what do you bring to the table for the
both portfolio companies but also in
part
a part of your investment thesis so tal
take us away
talk to me a little bit about your
journey where you're from and and how
you got to where you are
uh amazing so i was born and raised in
uh in the u.s
in new york new jersey i moved to israel
when i was about
16 and i've been here ever since did
kind of
spend some time in the army went to
went to hebrew university and was to be
honest my dream was always to be a
diplomat
um and from kind of that dream somehow i
became a venture capitalist
um but it's a little bit different
a little different but much of the same
what is the same between being a
diplomat and being a venture capitalist
so i'm really passionate about israel
and telling israel's phenomenal story
so as a venture capitalist i get the
opportunity to tell the
economic phenomena right right and i'm
telling you the political one and i feel
like
um that brings a lot of great things
together okay and
so growing up to become a diplomat what
does that entail is that like model
united nations and that sort of stuff or
how do you set yourself up to become a
diplomat and then make that rapid
transition into venture capital
so i took part in a lot of international
and global learning experiences and
conferences whether it was
you know the model u.n whether it was
international diplomacy
peace building humanitarian aid i was
traveling around the world and taking
part in
unique learning experiences in order to
acquire the
soft skills that will help me succeed
and the learning experiences that will
help me
become become better better
professionally
and uh and when i started university
i set out to study chinese and
international relations because i
thought that would position me
um in a very unique way of course
to go into foreign service because you
know not many people speak chinese
definitely not about it and it's more
relevant than ever
more relevant than ever and and that
actually took me to the business side
and not the
diplomatic side which was surprising and
i'm extremely grateful and happy about
that so what was your first
dip into the business side of things out
of the diplomacy side
so during my uh towards the end of my
first year
of university i decided to intern for
an incredible ceo rebecca's expert at
the
israel asia center which is an
incredible organization that basically
basically fosters collaborations between
israel
and all countries around asia
specifically around
economic economic ties okay
and that basically was my entry point to
kind of the
entire startup ecosystem here
here in israel i was hosting high-level
uh senior delegations of investors and
entrepreneurs and government officials
and connecting them
to them and connecting them to the local
ecosystems here were you were
able to use any of the chinese you
learned in university or was that not
even a part of it
uh you know my chinese is not not as
good
very very nice okay now talk to me a
little bit about this thing that you
founded which
you're empowering female leaders not
necessarily in tech but in all sectors
and and you're doing it in a pretty cool
way so tell me a little bit about what
that program was about
and then we'll transition to so to some
of the investments
about five years ago i found that i
co-founded
an organization called the women's
parliament that really fosters
female leadership across the board all
over israel
and for me personally was extremely
important to invest in mid-senior
leadership but also showcase
the various um various
you know israel is extremely unique
right we have a lot of different
sectors and societies and i wanted to
make sure that we
we have everyone uh everyone there as a
group
so we have women that
you know from the uh public sector from
the private sector from non-profits
from all across israel from you know
south
to north we have hearing women we have
arab women
we have um
new immigrants and this program really
sets out to help them
acquire skill sets that they're going to
need in order
to become the future leaders of israel
now what does that actually mean
tangibly so they join this program you
you identify these women
what do you actually do with them to get
to to make that leap
so we have meetings uh every we have
meetings every so often
with either thought leaders or
entrepreneurs
or government leaders that tell their
personal stories but also
give them help also provide a practical
skill that
that these females can use within their
own organizations
and through that we also foster
relationships and
and mentorship and friendships um
amongst the women that to really help
them increase
their network in order to succeed so
when i looked at my own network i said
okay i'm very much in high tech in the
startup echo system
i don't know anything else um around me
definitely not at the time right i
wanted
and if i want to succeed in a really
meaningful way um i need to establish
a much broader network and that's how
this kind of came to be
and that's what was so important for us
to to bring in women
that really depict all of israel's
society from
all different sectors and there have
been a lot of really great outcomes
and friendships and collaborations that
have come out of this incredible form
and so are there any common threads that
you've noticed
among the among the members in this
program where there are specific
specific things that that collectively
they need or collectively
are looking for as they join this
program and are making the leap
yes we we i think women as a whole
um have a lot of uh have a lot of
challenges as they
as they step up from from mid-level to
senior
level to executives and there's a lot
that always happens around negotiation
skills a lot about you know
internal politics a lot about management
right
when you move from from mid-level to
senior level and how do you manage a
team and how do you measure time
effectively a lot about productivity
a lot about um facilitation of
relationships and strategic partnerships
those are things that are common threads
that that cause industries to deal with
on a day-to-day level
and was it helpful that this is a
community that is strictly for women
in terms of in terms of their
empowerment because it's because all
these skills are hugely relevant to both
to both genders right
but but i'm but i'm trying to assess
whether the the fact that it's a
community that it's
by women for women gives them a little
bit more flexibility and more confidence
to go and utilize them
100 i think that it it provides a really
strong foundation where you're not
afraid to raise your hands and ask a
question
where you don't feel like you're
constantly being judged where you can
really come and be
yourself and be your authentic self
and uh and really create those
meaningful relationships that will
really help you take yourself to the
next level
wonderful okay tell so you you you
for went your uh your passion for
diplomacy to go into investing
today you're at pico you've had a couple
of other of other gigs with investing
before
talk to me a little bit about investing
what is investing for you and what do
you do specifically at pico that you're
so excited about
so at peaker at pico partners i have an
incredible opportunity to really work
with founders
we're really early stage fund so we're
normally kind of the first institutional
money in the company
so sometimes we invest really at the
idea phase so i get to work with
i get to work with entrepreneurs from
you know an idea and a presentation
and help them build companies and that's
something that's so exciting for me
everything from kind of the ideation to
the productization to the go-to-market
strategy to hiring
and business development um and setting
up shop clients in global countries
it's an incredible it's something that
you know gets me really excited to wake
up every day
so walk me through your day-to-day you
arrive in the morning or you're in the
beginning of the week at pico partners
and and what does the day in the life of
of todd talkner
look like every day is different and
there's no common thread
i spend a lot of time meeting with
entrepreneurs
and learning about new industries and
understanding whether
you know hearing a lot of pitches and
and trying to think whether these are
you know that
valuable businesses and scalable
businesses and that fit
um our investment thesis and a big part
of my work
also goes to actually working with the
entrepreneurs that i've invested in
you know on their daily challenges
making sure that you know we're going
through really rough times all around
the world pomona coven
19 has really impacted a lot of a lot of
businesses and a lot of markets globally
and i want to be
you know my entrepreneur's biggest
cheerleader and i want to make sure that
they have what it takes and i can be
helpful for them to make it through
successfully um and sometimes that
entails you know working with them
on hiring or refining their value
proposition or their go-to-market
strategy
um doing some market research and we
have i i do a lot of work
so how does that actually the process
start because the way that i'm
that i'm looking at especially in the
very very early stages so let's say the
ideation phase
you know the entrepreneurs become really
expert in this experts in this domain
they become truly passionate about this
what is your role as the institutional
fund that comes in and supports them
into helping them
you know encapsulate this ideation into
a product
hire and you know follow on to their
future investments how do you actually
go and follow these entrepreneurs
is it you know do you have like a set
things that you expect them to do or you
expect yourselves to do
or is it more dynamic for entrepreneur
it's
it's very dynamic for entrepreneur i
think different entrepreneurs you know
value and need different things um but
ultimately
i will never know about a sector or
specific technology better than the
entrepreneur that's there and working
day to day
but i do have an incredible benchmark
having seen
a lot of different companies a lot of
different scenarios
researching a lot of different markets
that i can come from with an outside
viewing
hey did you think about that hey this
worked well with this company why don't
you think
of utilizing this for for your use case
as well
and that's kind of i think where venture
capital is can be real value-add and
helpful to the
entrepreneurs okay and is there a
specific market that you're particularly
excited about or is it very agnostic
oh wow um so i'm very generalist and i'm
i'm very
agnostic but i'm extremely passionate
about the future of work digital health
space is something i'm looking a lot
into right now food tech i'm really
excited about
those are things that i'm really deep
diving on um but i
i look at i look at a lot of stuff so
give me a couple of insights into this
idea of digital health the future of the
workplace because obviously that's
something that's
hugely relevant to myself to anybody
that's listening on the show to any
entrepreneur that is starting out their
journey
what what are some of the trends that
you've been seeing over the past few
months and
and if i ask uh utah what do you think
are there are the
key cornerstones or key milestones in
the as we move along in this new reality
when i look at the future of work you
know the way we're working is going to
fundamentally change
we're now getting used to working
remotely what does that mean how do you
manage teams effectively
how do you secure the network think
about all these
you know heavy enterprises that you know
are on-prem how do how do employees
effectively work from home
connectivity um we spoke about
communication between
teams building culture all of that
there's so much opportunity and things
that are going to have to change in
in the data in our day-to-day right
no go ahead when i think about digital
health
this global pandemic really posed a lot
of
opportunities for companies to really
disrupt
remote care we see telemedicine right
now
booming how do you you know and i think
right now
consumers are used to getting a lot of
their
services remotely and i think that's
something that's going to be
very hard to go back to the old days so
i think right now when i look at
hospitals and i look at clinics and i
look at private practices and i look at
the payers
and they're going to have to do a lot of
a lot of work to transition
um and in order to stay relevant
and keep up with uh with the trend and
what consumers are expecting to have
right so what's important for you when
you meet an entrepreneur and
and you're considering joining them on
the journey what what sort of like your
thesis into
these are things that i'm excited about
and that i trust these are things that
i'm a little bit more worried about
and obviously this is something that
would go a long way for any young
entrepreneur watching this
so as an early stage investor the thing
i look at and spend the most time on
is the team um why are they
why do they choose to go after this this
specific
industry or problem why are they best
positioned to solve it
um what what you know
what are they most passionate about
what's the purpose behind what they're
doing and i think
you know you would know right
founding uh founding a startup and being
an entrepreneur or something that's
extremely difficult there
you know cycles of success are are never
linear
they're always needs and you need to
have a lot of resilience and a lot of
written words
in order to succeed and you need to be
very mission driven
um and so that's something that i spend
a lot of time on
and again i personally am excited about
things that
are going to change the way we live the
way we
consume things the way we operate that
will impact um
impact our lives and also on the other
hand kind of operational
efficiency um innovative business models
fixing broken business processes and old
industries which is what's exciting for
me in digital health for instance
um so i look on the team and the market
opportunity primarily
so one of the things that i'm always
very excited about is the and or very
interested in
is how different institutions come
into a startup and and now have to sort
of play
a similar role different role depending
on the round that they join
how do you as an investor come in and
see this relationship also with other
investors
who come into the startup whether at
your at your stage or the different
round and all of a sudden now you have
sometimes conflicting ideas conflicting
strategies
and obviously at the end the
entrepreneur directs the path but
but how do you then sort of create this
harmony between the different
institutional investors within a startup
it's something that sometimes is hard to
do and it's sometimes
challenging and often and often great
we all have a shared interest which is
the success of the company
and we're all there to be the company's
greatest cheerleader
and ultimately you know we might have
different ideas but i think our
our job as investors is to ask the right
questions and the challenging questions
and to get the entrepreneur to think a
bit outside the box or even take the
opportunity to reflect
like importance you know we take we take
an opportunity to reflect three months
back and
look you know three months six months
two years forward and really plan and
strategize
and that's where i think we can be most
helpful and i think where we all have a
common
common thread and when you say we you're
meaning yourselves and the other
institutional investors right yes
us and uh any other investors around
very very very cool
tal you know right before we get to my
favorite question i want
what is the one thing that's most
exciting for you in this whole in this
whole journey whether it's you know
meeting the entrepreneurs or
or watching different industries in
different markets boom what is really
the most exciting for you about this
about being an investor because you did
have ambitions to go into other sectors
but obviously you're having so much fun
what are you doing now
i feel so grateful to to be the enabler
and to help entrepreneurs
you know fulfill their dreams i think
it's it's a great it's
incredible opportunity and it's what you
know wakes me up and keeps me excited
every day
i love it i love it okay and three words
that you would use to describe yourself
um execution driven authentic and
resilient
okay explain a little bit more about
these why why these three words
so i'm extremely execution driven i
know how to take you know a lot of ideas
and put them into
into processes and execute on them and i
help
i helped build those frameworks with my
entrepreneurs as well i think it's a
it's a
it's it's part of the great value that i
bring as an investor
um authentic it's it's it's who i am
it's my course it's it's part of me
um and uh resilience uh resilience is
an important part of my job as uh as i
feel as a as a young woman and uh in
tekken and the investment world
um it takes that it takes a lot of
resilience and a lot of grit
um which i share with the entrepreneurs
i invest in as well
and it's a big part of how i see um
you know my core values and moving
forward i love it and one thing you
would say to a young entrepreneur just
starting their journey
you know now during the pandemic they
decided to go and start a startup
what would you tell them keep at it
and you know keep working really hard
listen to your customers gain market
feedback and you know you know better
than all the investors so don't take
no as as a reason not to go and fulfill
your dream i love it
tal thank you very much to daraba best
of luck with pico partners
this was fantastic thank you appreciate
it thank you
take care